today's an exciting day bitcoin hitting
45 000. i saw you tweeting up a storm
all kinds of different thoughts how are
you feeling about sentiment in uh on
twitter and kind of in the market in
general
i'm good you know it's it's pretty mixed
um
you know i feel like some people are
still kind of in disbelief but you do
have a few people in the timeline who
are kind of euphoric so
seems like a good kind of mix here i
mean general
vibe does kind of feel like disbelief
though
hey but uh what bears have to remember
is that you could be bearish at certain
points and you may make a little bit of
money but ultimately you're picking up
pennies in front of the steam rule this
is a decades-long trend and we only
going up and so bears when the battle
bowls when the war starts facts
you should be on a plaque somewhere for
saying that that's a great uh great
thing all right talk to us about some of
these charts you got first is you've got
the uh this price chart you got a whole
bunch of different levels uh green and
red that are outlined here what is this
showing us
yeah as you just said these are
basically just price levels i drew out
i think the
the kind of main point i wanted to just
get across here was just saying that i
think at this point
we're kind of right below major
resistance and so from like a short-term
kind of trading perspective
uh i don't think the rr here being you
know like gig along is great until we
clear that resistance
um you know you never want to buy right
below resistance you never want to sell
you know right before we hit major
support and so just from that
perspective um as we're kind of pressing
up against that major resistance
um you know if i was a short-term trader
and i wasn't already long i would kind
of just you know wait out to see what
the reaction here is at this level but
nonetheless again we're approaching this
you know major resistance level both
kind of in this consolidation pattern
that we've been in as well as just you
know horizontal price structure uh going
back over the last year or so which is
right around 46 47 k
that's also around the yearly open
there's a few different moving averages
over there as well
but that's kind of a you know as i feel
like we've been talking about for
several weeks or whatever
um that's kind of a key level that i've
been watching
and then another kind of
well i have two other ways you can look
at confluence with this in addition
everything i just said
the first one is the next chart which is
short term holder cost basis
so we talked about this last week so i
don't want to like repeat myself too
much
but essentially this is the aggregated
cost basis of all market participants
that have been in the market for less
than 155 days or less than five months
um
and right now this kind of aggregated
cost basis sits at forty six thousand
two hundred
it does kind of move around a bit you
know week to week whenever we speak but
generally it's been hanging out around
46 to 47 k
as of today it's sitting at 46
200
and then last kind of thing that i
wanted to point out for on the
confluence of 46 to 47k being kind of an
important level
is the third chart
the third chart is looking at basically
a heat map of all the bids and asks
across different venues in particular
in this chart we're looking at biff and
x
the reason we're looking at bitfinex
biffin x has a higher hit rate than
most of the other venues uh if not they
have the highest hit rate uh kind of
back testing looking at all of the kind
of you know quote unquote walls that
they set on the bid and ask side
generally speaking you know biff and x
tends to kind of be the the you know
smart money in a sense and whenever they
kind of you know place either a buy or
cell wall that tends to have some uh
dictation on on future price movement
uh and so what we see currently is that
they had just actually in the last hour
or so
kind of set this ask wall between 45 and
and 48k so that's confluence as well um
you're seeing some some you know large
asks step in from from different x in
particular
what you don't want to see
is like a partial fill
so
this seems kind of counter-intuitive um
like what you want to see for bowls in
this scenario because we're talking
about an ask wall you want to actually
see it fully get filled see all their
orders get filled and conversely if it
was a bid wall what bears would want to
see is you know full fill of the bid
wall the reason is because like the
market basically moves
in two ways it moves because of you know
effort and absorption
so effort being active orders they're
stepping in right so when you just go on
you know whatever venue you're using to
allocate the bitcoin you just market buy
right you're buying at the the market
price it's like if you go on ebay right
and you hit and you hit buy it now right
you're willing to maybe pay a little bit
higher of a premium just to go ahead and
get the exposure and lock in your your
purchase right
and then there's limit orders and limit
orders are essentially saying i like to
use this ebay analogy because i think it
i think it makes someone of sense um you
know you go on ebay something's listed
for fifty dollars you don't wanna pay
fifty dollars you say well i don't deem
that fair value for this item but i'll
step in and place a bid at you know 40
bucks if it fills great you know that's
where i i think this is you know worth
my you know purchasing power if not then
that's cool you know it didn't reach
what i think is fair value it's the same
thing in the order book for bitcoin
right and so people come in and they set
limit orders
both on the bid and ask side
and so whenever you see you know a clump
of bids or asks or wall
whenever you see that fully fill
that means that the effort in the market
is is you know outweighing the
absorption
so in this case if we see this ask wall
get fully filled to me what that's
indicating is that the effort or the
active orders uh is outpacing the amount
of absorption or the the this wall of
asks that we're looking at now or limit
orders that we're that we're looking at
now
um so that's what i would be looking at
you know kind of the bearish scenario
would be these bids fill like 60 70 and
then price reverses because at that
point it's it's showing you that the
amount of effort in the market couldn't
outpace the amount of absorption that
was set out if that makes sense um but
yeah aside from
everything i just said specifically
talking about the order books across the
board looking at order books on chain
and technical analysis all three are
showing that the kind of 4647k area is
an important level for btc
um and so when you talk about kind of
you know this other framework that we've
been talking about it's kind of there's
value buyers and momentum buyers right
and so i think for a lot of those kind
of momentum market participants or trend
following strategies a lot of those will
kind of trigger if we can get above that
area hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time